ميسي يعود الى برشلونه يمنع زيدان من
قياده يوفنتوس والجماهير اليونانيه تقتحم
درب العاصمه هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها
لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
لا تزال التكهنات تحيط بمستقبل ليونيل
ميسي قبل شهرين ونصف من انتهاء عقده مع
باريس سان جيرمان بطل العالم ظهر خلال
الساعات الماضيه في مدينه برشلونه كما
التقطت عدسه احدى الكاميرات ميسي وهو
يتجول في المدينه علمتني درجه هوائيه
وكانت تقارير اعلاميه اسبانيه قد تحدثت عن
امكانيه عوده الارجنتيني الى النادي
الكتالوني الموسم المقبل كما ربطت هذه
الزياره باجتماع مرتقى بين ليونيل واعضاء
من البلوغرام
اكدت اذاعه مونتي كارلو الفرنسيه اقتراب
زيدان من تدريب يوفنتوس الايطالي خلال
الموسم المقبل لكن يبدو ان فك الارتباط
بين ماكس اليغري واليوفي لن يكون سهلا 18
مليون يورو هي الشرق الجزائري للمدرب
الايطالي ان اراد يوفنتوس الاستغناء عن
خدماته خاصه وان فريق السيده العجوز هذا
الموسم يعاني من خسائر كبيره على المستوى
المالي
[موسيقى]
خبر اخر يخص نادي يوفنتوس الذي تنفس مشجعه
السعداء عقب اعاده النقاط التي سحبت منه
في وقت سابق لكن في الجهه المقابله بدا
الاتحاد الاوروبي لكره القدم بتحقيق مستقل
بعد استقباله لوثائق من مكتب المدعي العام
في مدينه تورينو وقد يعاقب الفريق
بالحرمان من المشاركه في البطولات القاريه
الموسم المقبل انثبت تورطه في قضيه
التلاعب برواتب اللاعبين
لم يكن الحاكم الايطالي ديفيد ماسا يعلم
بان ادارته لدرب اثينا في الدوري اليوناني
ستخرج عن السيطره قاد مباراه اولمبياكوس
اثينا الحاسمه في بطوله الدوري لكن
النهايه لم تكن سعيده حيث اقتحم مشجع
اولمبياكوس ملعب فريقهم احتجاجا على عدم
منح فريقه الجزائر كما اشتبكوا مع فرد
الشرطه الذين اطلقوا الغاز الموسيلي
للدموع لتفريخ الجماهير الغاضبه
[موسيقى]